and finally new rule conservatives who
constantly whine that christianity
is under attack from liberals have to
explain why there are over 300
000 churches in the u.s but only 400
whole foods
clearly your side is winning
now i understand it christians love to
feel persecuted it's part of their
origin story
but we're a long way from them getting
eaten by lions in the coliseum
70 percent of the country is christian
not to mention every president we've
ever had
so please tell me in what universe do
the following statements make sense
mike huckabee says we are moving rapidly
toward the criminalization of
christianity
ted cruz says there's no room for
christians in today's democratic party
what 80 percent of democrats in congress
are christian
and 78 percent of democratic governors
you can look this [ __ ] up you know
ted also said there is a liberal fascism
that is going after christian believers
going after fascism i don't even believe
in christ but for christ's sake
martyr much bill o'reilly says if you're
a christian or a white man in the usa
it's open season on you
yes that explains all those recent
videos of police shooting unarmed white
clergymen
rick santorum says the treatment of
christians in america is so bad
we she should keep in mind nazi germany
where you go from christians jews
obviously but also
christians being not just persecuted but
put to death
again 70 of america is christian
who's going to put them to death the
hindus
this idea that everybody on the left is
plotting against christianity
and wants to wipe out religion is
offensive
to me because i'm the only media figure
with a show week in and week out that
says that
and i'll be damned if the credit's going
to go to the entire left when i'm doing
all the heavy lifting
well well i actually
there are two others who have been my
allies in this
because that's the rule of america you
can mock religion if you're a cartoon
dog or a child in a cartoon
but when jeb bush says how strange in
our own time to hear christianity spoken
of as some sort of backward and
oppressive force
who else is talking about it that way
is it nancy pelosi no
harry reid no obama
he says he wakes up to scripture on his
blackberry
obama does every show on tv except this
one because he can't even be seen with
an atheist
i gave him a million dollars he treats
me like i lent him a million dollars
so who who are we talking about hillary
no bill biden al gore
al franken elizabeth warren jesse
jackson who
nobody that's who sean hannity says
the liberal media's war against religion
is alive and well
okay so it's more of the media thing
like
like my friend ariana from the liberal
huffington post
because she's written three books about
faith i know because we argue about it
after sex
is it the liberal gang at msnbc
because i've never heard any of them say
anything anti-religion
one of them is a reverend one of them
attacks me when i
attack religion is it the late night
guys because
i never hear any of them do it either is
it ellen
or rosie or chelsea we know it's not
oprah
michael moore he's the liberal
republicans hate the most he
no he's a catholic this guy's so
catholic he teaches sunday school
on sunday in the morning
when normal people are just getting in
from an after party
i really want to know where is religion
belittled in the liberal world
the new york times editorial page no
the times op-ed page no any newspapers
any page
no newsweek in time they put jesus on
the cover more often than cat fancy puts
a cat
are we talking about athletes if they so
much as
fart on the field they point to the sky
and give god credit
football players have prayer circles
after the game and only half of them
have the excuse of brain damage
so who
i'm getting mad like you it's catching
maybe they mean counter culture types
like devilish musicians
really have you ever watched an award
show every speeches
i want to thank jesus without whom i
never would have written face down ass
up
you